i'm the same and i can be a little
socially awkward too like i don't like a
lot of attention when i go places i want
to go but very much like hey can you put
me in the corner it took me years to
admit that i was celebrity somebody
famous i don't get that i don't
understand it ramona
we're on a tv show tv show that makes a
host thing how long have you been on the
show now i started in 2006.
so you're 13 years i've been around with
her from the beginning start out with
orange county i know i knew who orange
county was you and i was in new york
city put bravo on the map with a
franchise okay
[Applause]
i know my facts one thing i know the
facts our show came on and you know what
we were in
first week wall street journal daily
news we were called a cool water show
people get the next morning and talk
about us by their water cooler water
cooler night cold water
so because of us then you all came
[Applause]
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome i've never been number one
we're international cynthia in our own
mind
in our own lives
it's like saying because of me you're
here right now which is not a good way
to start call me when you invented a
move that defines a franchise i
literally invented table flipping
new york maybe she got them confused
maybe it's her dementia right now
beverly hills has the highest rating so
excuse me everyone i would like to have
everyone's attention
this is brooklyn
what
[Applause]
this is the first time kenya has left
this little girl in two and a half years
i have been through it with her i've
seen the evolution of this beautiful
relationship this is a big deal
because this is really the first time
this woman has left her child and i know
all the mothers here can
relate to that
[Music]
so kenya more
in your
celebration of you cutting the umbilical
cord
say i'm proud of you
love you
and we're going to have a bomb ass time
in turks and caicos we've got these days
together
don't use these sam simpson
all right you can cut the corner i don't
know i might have to cut a [ __ ] with
these
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
matt i love scissors
cynthia that was so thoughtful
[Applause]
having my girlfriend cynthia with me
definitely makes things a lot easier i
have so many sources of stress in my
life and she knows them more than anyone
else
in the spirit of kenya not only leaving
her baby for the first time she's also
going through
a divorce i actually yeah i have a court
date or date while we're here it's just
a lot this is a lot so i would like to
request that we think about considering
giving kenya the master
[Music]
i think it's a little bit out of left
field i mean everybody could sit here
and say they have a reason why they
should have the master bedroom i'm fine
to give up my room to make sure you have
a nice room wow kenya that's a
girlfriend right there i didn't realize
they were such great friends i don't
know ramona i don't know if she would do
the same
i remember when i was getting divorced i
think i lost like 15 pounds i couldn't
eat it is traumatic i mean going through
a divorce so yeah i agree give it to
kenya and i'll take one of the next best
rooms i just want to tell you about
tonight what's going to happen because
i'm hosting i know everyone's doing
something different every night i
contacted my friend john mcdonald he
owns this really great restaurant it's
on the ocean beach whatever and he has
great music it's called the conch shack
actually luanne and i were there like
like four or five six years ago aha i'll
never forget don't tell them this is the
one that you cock-block everybody
she went in and said i don't give a [ __ ]
about these girls i might marry this guy
and live on this island no i don't know
i was into him i was flirting i was into
him oh okay wait a minute what happened
that was when i decided i couldn't be
with my ex-husband anymore it was over
you were married at the time yeah so you
were flirting with him no he's getting
divorced he's cheating on me for a year
jess said you were flirting with him one
minute ago yeah because i was getting
divorced [ __ ] wait what
yeah it's you because you don't
understand anything i said
why are you calling me a baby
[Music]
you